ضحايا هذا العدوان الاسرائيلي جزء كبير
منها من الاطفال والنساء هذه جنى ابنه ال
15 عاما هي ضحيه العدوان الاسرائيلي مما
ادى الى بتر قدمها اليمنى واصابه القدم
الاخرى في قصف اسرائيلي كنا
قاعدين فجاه كل الدار بتصير غبره فجاه
رجلي بتنفجر
قدامي جلدي طلع على ايدي فجاه كل الدار
بتصير غبره انا قاع اصرخ كل و رؤوس الناس
رؤوس الناس اللي كانوا معنا في الدار كلها
كانت مليانه دم انا كنت كنت امشي كنت العب
كنت كنت كنت افرح من اللعب هلقيت ولا شيء
هلقيت دائما كل يوم وجع كل يوم عذاب كل
يوم وجع رجعوا لي رجلي زي ما كانت انا بدي
اتعلم بدي بدي انا انا اصفي في الطابق
الرابع انا كيف بدي كيف بدي اطلع على
الدرج انا كيف بدي امشي كيف بدي اتعلم
حرموني الطفوله حرموني وين هي جمعيه حقوق
الطفل وين جمعيه حقوق المدنيين في الحروب
احمونا احمونا كنا
قاعدين
نايمين ها مفجاه ضرب اول حاجه عننا جامع
اسمه سلف الصالح قصفوا متور وبعدها قصفوا
الارض بعديه قصفوا دارنا انا طلعوني من
تحت الردم انا واخوتي الاثنين والباقي كله
مقطع
طلعوه ابويا وامي وستي وعمتي وخالتي كلهم
كلهم ماضل حد عندي مازل بدي تبنو الدار رب
اخوتي اخوتك اصغر منها اه واحد صفاني
وواحد اول والله انا جاي مع طفله مها رشاد
العرعير الناجيه الوحيده من قصف الاحتلال
شقه
مدنيه الطفله تعرضت لتشوه كامل في الوجه
تعاني من قله
توفر المستلزمات الطبيه ونحن
نناشد الاخوه في الخارج الى انها تكمل
رحلتها العلاجيه للخارج باسرع وقت
ممكن معاناه وقصف مستمر حرب اباده اهدافها
الاطفال
والنساء حتى باتت المستشفيات محاصره
ومدمره في شمال
القطاع اسم اسيل الغول الجزيره مدينه غزه